I heard Jane you relax with like baths
and meditations is it true that there
also might be an adult toy involved
[Applause]
oh there is
sitting on it there's my bed there's my
dresser and in the top dresser drawer
you would freak out if you saw what's in
there what
I need some help Jane can you help me
yeah I will I'm just wait till we step
outside of this room what
what what is in this box take your hands
off oh my God
I'm sorry sorry
especially for you
I have a
I have an adult toy you do
it
thank you
thank you so much
hello
other than my two daughters now but up
until they were born which was only a
decade ago my whole life existed around
my friends I didn't have family it was
always my friends and the way that you
two speak about friendship and represent
it I just think is one of the most
important things that you know you put
out into this world amongst so many
other wonderful things yeah so thank you
for advocating the way you do
for friendship and I love your new movie
called moving on everybody in fact we
have a clip let's take a let's take a
quick look
so how's your hip
my hips fine so it's just your arm
yes it's just my arm that seems broken I
guess that's lucky I mean for your hip
yeah oh God be careful
oh my God
that was a stop sign I can see that now
how long has it been since you had a
license
um eight years
I mean
Grace and Frankie ended after seven
years
seven years of playing those two
characters ten days later
ten days after we finished Grace and
Frankie we started filming moving on and
one of the joys for me we we knew that
it was really important to be playing
characters that were completely
different than Grace and Frankie right
was watching her
be this
totally different person
from the person I had been playing
opposite 10 days earlier and that's what
you fell in love with when you saw in
that one woman play the chameleon she is
yes I mean the body of work that both of
you have individually and collectively
leads me to ask you if you'll play my
favorite game with me sure I'll play any
game okay it's a game called
come on
now I'm looking for I'll mention a few
films that you've done together and
individually so I'm wondering if you got
a dirty detail a fly on the wall moment
something we didn't know about a memory
that Sparks when I say nine to five
foreign
oh my God I don't think we ever stopped
laughing on that movie no we laughed
quite a bit
um mostly at Dolly's costumes
yeah and the fact that she couldn't see
her hands when she was typing
she my son was about six then uh-huh and
she said Troy do you know why my feet
are so small
laughs
I remember and he looked up to me like
am I supposed to say something here
and he was just bright red and she said
things don't grow big in the shade
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]